i
[Música]
los ucranianos retomando el control de
toda la región de kiev según el
ministerio de defensa el presidente
volodymyr selenski denuncia que las
tropas rusas están dejando minas
antipersonales en su retirada mientras
que las fuerzas de moscú se concentran
en el este
recta final de las presidenciales en
francia en el último fin de semana de
campaña antes de los comicios del 10 de
abril los candidatos realizaron mítines
incluso de manuel ma con quien hasta
ahora no había hecho un evento de este
tipo
hoy es el día mundial sobre
concienciación sobre el autismo en esta
emisión hablaremos de qué es el
trastorno de espectro autista cuáles son
los avances frente a la enfermedad y
cómo la pandemia ha impactado a los
menores de edad que la padecen
bienvenidos a france 24 estas son las
noticias internacionales y yo soy maría
clara calle empezamos hablando de la
guerra en ucrania y es que las tropas
ucranianas retomando el control de toda
la región de kiev donde está la capital
del país así lo informó la viceministra
de defensa jan a mayer a través de su
página de facebook con esto las
autoridades confirman el retiro de las
tropas rusas de esta región sin embargo
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
scheleske advirtió que el ejército de
moscú estaría dejando minas
antipersonales de donde se repliega
mientras tanto rusia está fortaleciendo
su control militar hacia el este en la
región separatista del donbass más
temprano un asesor de la presidencia
ucraniana afirmó que la liberación de
kiev comenzó por 30 pueblos de la región
pronto muy durante el día las
principales maniobras de acción fueron
la región de kiev donde desde el
noroeste y noreste de kiev nuestro
ejército golpeó con éxito el enemigo
hacia la frontera y liberó a más de 30
localidades ocupadas
y yuri shmidt era una de las ciudades
recuperadas escucha al noroeste de kiev
y lo que se encontraron las autoridades
fue impactante los cuerpos de por lo
menos 20 personas muertas estaban
tirados en el suelo
los soldados ucranianos ataron cables a
los cadáveres y los movieron de las
calles temiendo que pudieran tener
explosivos atados a ellos la alcaldía de
lucha denuncia que al menos 300 personas
fueron enterradas en fosas comunes por
los rusos antes de que estos se fueran
aunque esta información no ha sido
verificada por otras fuentes
y en irvine a las afueras de kiev
hallaron una ciudad devastada aunque las
fuerzas ucranianas hicieron retroceder a
las tropas rusas los escombros reflejan
los intensos bombardeos que padecieron
los habitantes desde marzo allí no hay
ni agua ni gas ni electricidad nuestros
colegas de france 2 recorrieron irving y
esto fue lo que vieron a sólo 25
kilómetros de kiev bloquear el avance
ruso en el fin era fundamental para las
fuerzas ucranianas pero no queda mucho
de lo que un día fue un suburbio y lleno
de vida sus calles residenciales y
edificios están marcados por el fuego de
artillería y la ciudad está siniestra
mente tranquila
desde principios de marzo no hay agua
gas ni electricidad y la mayoría de los
residentes de irving huyeron esta mujer
es una de las pocas personas que quedan
en su barrio se llama jelena y tiene 65
años
ninguno de mis vecinos se quedó todos
fueron evacuados después de casi 40 días
de guerra rara vez ha salido de su
apartamento
me estaba volviendo loca en mi
apartamento el dios por favor sálvame
sálvame el bombardeo fue aterrador mira
a tu alrededor
de los antiguos 70.000 habitantes de la
ciudad quedan unos 3500 gran parte de
ellos son mayores y vulnerables no te
oye cómo voy a salir de mi casa estoy
sola esperé a que me ayudarán antes todo
esto era tan bonito eran muy bonitos y
ahora mira todo es una tragedia
el viernes un equipo de trabajadores de
la cruz roja pudo acceder al centro de
la ciudad para proporcionar alimentos y
ayuda esencial en este parque cercano
algunos de los residentes de irving
fueron enterrados aunque las tropas
rusas han sido forzadas a salir del pib
la ciudad sigue estando al alcance de la
artillería enemiga y el mariupol sigue
en los esfuerzos por evacuar a civiles
allí quedan al menos 100.000 habitantes
de los más de 400.000 que había antes el
comité internacional de la cruz roja
intentó hoy entrar por segunda vez
consecutiva esta semana para sacar a
pobladores pero el ministerio de defensa
rusa dijo que el organismo otra vez no
pudo entrar a mariupol en los esfuerzos
del viernes el pse icr afirmó que era
porque los bombardeos rusos continuaban
y hoy moscú dice que el operativo no se
realizó porque el equipo del comité
llegó muy tarde aún así el vice primer
ministro de ucrania afirmó que
setecientos sesenta y cinco residentes
lograron salir de la ciudad en vehículos
privados
1325 civiles han muerto en la guerra en
ucrania esa es la cifra más reciente de
la oficina de la onu para los derechos
humanos a la lista se suma el
fallecimiento del fotógrafo máximo levin
un ucraniano que fue colaborador de la
agencia internacional reuters
el fotorreportero desapareció desde el
13 de marzo cuando cubría la guerra en
kiev ahora la fiscalía ucraniana
encontró su cuerpo con dos disparos esta
entidad responsabiliza a las fuerzas
armadas rusas
dennis herrera tiene los detalles la
guerra arremete nuevamente contra el
periodismo el sábado se confirmó el
asesinato de un fotógrafo ucraniano su
cuerpo fue encontrado al norte de la
capital
maxim levin trabajaba para un medio
ucraniano y era colaborador de reuters
entre otros medios internacionales el
periodista había decidido ir al pueblo
de emoción donde hubo fuertes
enfrentamientos este asesinato se suma a
la lista de nombres de periodistas que
han muerto en terreno desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa brain renault fue el
primero donde su colega juan arredondo
ciudadano colombo estadounidense resultó
herido
cruzamos el primer puente en irvine y
vamos a filmar a refugiados que se iban
nos subimos a un auto
alguien se ofreció a llevarnos al otro
puente y cruzamos el control donde
empezaron a disparar
reporteros sin fronteras ha informado
que desde que empezó la guerra dos
periodistas ucranianos han muerto y tres
extranjeros en el terreno los
periodistas se expresan sentirse
amenazados todo el tiempo que hubo
momentos en los cuales pensé que mi vida
corría peligro pero creo que esto es la
normalidad para todos los colegas que en
este momento
están informando sobre ucrania en el
terreno hay bombardeos a explosiones hay
disparos
eso que hemos contado nosotros lo hemos
visto con nuestros ojos las autoridades
ucranianas han informado que los
asesinatos se han dado a causa de los
ataques rusos sin embargo esa
información no se ha confirmado hasta el
momento por otras fuentes mientras
organizaciones de derechos humanos han
exigido a ambas naciones garantizar la
seguridad de los periodistas en medio de
la guerra
rusia podría retirarse de la cooperación
con occidente en la estación espacial
internacional si no levantan las
sanciones contra moscú así lo dijo y
dmitri rogózin jefe de la agencia
especial rusa roscósmos en la televisión
estatal y luego en telegram afirmó que
los proyectos conjuntos con eeuu canadá
la unión europea y japón sólo serán
posibles cuando levanten las sanciones
económicas contra rusia según rogózin
las autoridades de moscú pronto
decidirán si retirarse de la estación
espacial internacional
en otras noticias hungría celebra
elecciones parlamentarias este domingo
que determinarán quién será el próximo
primer ministro aunque el
ultraderechista viktor orbán es favorito
para una cuarta legislatura consecutiva
por primera vez se enfrenta a una
oposición unida que está a poco menos de
un punto porcentual de diferencia en las
encuestas además la guerra en ucrania
podría jugarle en contra al primer
ministro por su cercanía al gobierno
ruso luís muñoz tiene toda la
información en el siguiente reporte
12 años en el gobierno le convierten en
el primer ministro de la unión europea
más longevo el ultraderechista viktor
orbán es el favorito pero de forma muy
ajustada según las encuestas para las
elecciones del domingo
europac sugiero que este no es momento
para experimentar no intentemos cosas
nuevas ahora confiamos en la experiencia
la previsibilidad y nuestros
representantes probados los juegos un
poquito
los húngaros también votarán un
referendo decidirán si las escuelas
pueden hacer talleres de orientación
sexual orbán califica esto la locura de
género la oposición hace campaña
nos gustaría detener esta incitación al
odio y creemos que el voto nulo es lo
mejor para el referéndum caballas en
2018 fides el partido de orbán obtuvo el
66 por ciento de los escaños para
terminar con su gobierno la oposición
desde conservadores a izquierdistas se
ha unido le representa el candidato
peter marquis ai
la elección nunca ha sido tan fácil como
ahora aunque la papeleta de votación
tenga muchos son los naranjas de fides
hay una buena opción contra ellos elegir
europa en lugar del este
[Música]
la guerra de ucrania está en el centro
de la campaña urbana cusa a la izquierda
de querer enviar armas a kiev el actual
primer ministro no lo ha permitido
tampoco el paso de cargamentos de otros
países por su territorio es el mayor
aliado de vladimir putin en la unión
europea
que está en juego a donde pertenecemos y
hungría está en el sistema de alianzas
la otan y la unión europea de la que es
miembro o intenta una especie de estilo
único inclinándose hacia el este o media
con tokio
organizaciones como freedom house
consideran a hungría un estado híbrido
alejado de la democracia los problemas
de corrupción y los enfrentamientos con
bruselas han sido habituales mientras
que orbán presume de gestión económica
francia también se prepara para las
elecciones el próximo 10 de abril será
la primera vuelta de las presidenciales
en la recta final los candidatos hacen
sus últimos esfuerzos para convencer a
los indecisos que son cerca del 37% de
los electores según las últimas
encuestas por eso gran parte de los 12
aspirantes al elíseo realizaron mítines
políticos hoy incluso el presidente y
candidato en manuel majo quien no se ha
mostrado mucho durante la campaña los
detalles con la ugel
últimas oportunidades para los
candidatos franceses pero un primer y
único mitin para emanuel manjón entonces
en las afueras de parís la estrategia
del presidente saliente para convencer a
los indecisos sigue siendo la defensa de
su balance
si estoy comprometido con el objetivo
del pleno empleo
[Aplausos]
porque gracias a todo lo que hemos hecho
juntos durante estos cinco años por
primera vez desde mediados de los años
setenta
nuestro país puede decir que en los
próximos cinco años alcanzará el pleno
empleo si es posible
del lado de la izquierda también hubo
mítines el candidato del nuevo partido
anticapitalista film to habló frente a
un público de la capital cuando el
candidato del partido comunista fabián
hoss él estaba más al sur cerca de lyon
su objetivo distinguirse de los demás
prometiendo atacar a la delincuencia de
cuello blanco no
hablemos ataque a la nunca han querido
abordar el fraude y la evasión fiscal
onu ue pues para nosotros sí lo digo hoy
y a estas alturas de la campaña será una
prioridad aumentar el presupuesto del
estado reforzar nuestros servicios
públicos aumentar los salarios y las
pensiones
otra ciudad recibiendo un candidato
marsella donde erick de visitó al
mercadillo ilegal
hay que limpiar esto físicamente limpiar
a la gente que está haciendo todos estos
tráficos enviarlos de vuelta a su lugar
de origen porque en su mayoría son
ilegales de cualquier nacionalidad que
sean hay que enviarlos de vuelta a casa
y no dejarlos aquí por siempre
mañana otros cinco candidatos ofrecerán
mítines más traición típicas del winter
y acto en parís
sonic relación en toulouse y son las
salen y clausurando un fin de semana de
última oportunidad antes de la votación
del 10 de abril
hoy 2 de abril se conmemora el día
mundial de concienciación sobre el
autismo la onu que es el organismo que
promueve esta fecha explica que el
trastorno de espectro autista es una
afección neurológica que se manifiesta
desde la infancia
previamente hablamos con ana milena
jiménez ella es administradora del grupo
autismo colombia nos explicó cómo la
falta de presencialidad en las escuelas
durante la pandemia afectó a los menores
con autismo y también nos contó cuáles
son los retos que enfrenta una familia
donde uno de los miembros padece este
trastorno cuando se vive en torno al
autismo es importante saber y reconocer
que se vive en un mundo de segregaciones
y exclusiones de allí han sido unos
retos importantes sobre todo para
reconocer sus estilos de aprendizaje
revisar un poco más también este trabajo
de apoyo a familias que es tan relevante
y también posibilitar esas acciones
desde las políticas públicas educativas
particularmente que garanticen pues un
enfoque de derechos para todos los niños
y niñas que tienen la condición esa es
como el reto que tenemos hoy estamos en
una transición evidentemente donde hay
muchos retos en el tema de la post
pandemia alrededor de la educación pero
confiamos en que todos estos tránsitos
nos traigan las experiencias importantes
significativas y valiosas alrededor de
la atención y cobertura
para la población tanto para la infancia
a la adolescencia a la adultez los retos
son muchísimos a medida que van
creciendo en la adolescencia y pues para
la población adulta se van minimizando
esas brechas de participación para ellos
aquí el trabajo se da desde una labor
intersectorial desde las políticas
públicas que garanticen pues toda esa
ruta de atención de acuerdo a este
enfoque diferencial reconociendo
particularmente esas habilidades que
tienen cada una de las personas que se
encuentran dentro de la condición del
espectro autista hasta aquí las noticias
sigan con nosotros
[Música]